[Musique]
à croire à la plage
horrible horrible
quel honneur
c'est beau les motrices non plus alors
là dedans
a commenté ben may
bien voir que des ailes je serai le plus
heureux du roulage un jeune ali il en
faut pour tous les goûts
aujourd'hui pour laisser voler mais si
c'est quand même bien on aurait bien
aimé jean jacques hopin révélations
[Musique]
c'est leur vote c'est la mode à l'iphone
le poids normal
décidément les adolescents commandes
après leur musique voici qu'il impose
les mini-jeux bien sur l'adolescence et
de tous les âges
mais jusqu'à quel âge précisément ci est
elle aux femmes dont manuel ça va on n'a
pas froid
[Musique]
m
pourquoi pensez-vous des munitions sur
iphone ce samedi etes-vous vol là je ne
sais pas
est-ce que les ou la naissance non pas
du tout parce qu'elle est ce que vous
allez voir
non je n'ai pas froid est ce que oui à
l'école est ce que les critiques des
gens vous gêne non pas du tout 10 le
méchouar is on les aimes ton est plus
méchant les jeunes les jeunes filles
sont absolument d'accord les vieilles
femmes sont gentils ça les amuse mais la
prose par contre les femmes de 40 à 50
ans on sent très méchante grossière sont
certainement très jalouse mon principe
une femme de 40 ans peut pas se
permettre de porter des jupes aussi
courte
c'est pas ça leur plaît c'est que en
principe non pas pas beaucoup de femmes
ont envie de rester petite fille de
madame madame je voudrais une minijupe
ou les renards que donne déjà une très
claire dans les tons sinclair marsden
gens comme celle ci par exemple pour 1
ce matin voilà petit lait
[Musique]
la malade voyez jusqu'où madame au moods
elle lui vient paie leurs ateliers
oui moi il me plombe
voilà madame oui oui cet été
certainement ça fera fureur mais s'en
tiendra pas longtemps certainement fans
je trouve ça vraiment indécent comme ça
oui je trouve ça un décembre je la porte
parce que parce que ça me plait monsieur
ça m'amuse comme ça pour me faire
remarquer pour mais autrement non grata
[Musique]
où